justice department says it will join the
investigation into the controversial
police killing
of a black man in columbus ohio
23-year-old casey goodson
jr was his name he died after a
sheriff's deputy shot him on friday
afternoon
goodson's family says that he was shot
in the back at his own home
authorities say that goodson refused an
order to drop a gun
jeff begayes is at the justice
department with more on this story jeff
good morning to you
it's a song that we've heard many many
times but in this particular case
why are the federal authorities getting
involved now
well gail the justice department is
reviewing the details of this case which
as you note are
in dispute this morning but the goodson
family they want
concrete answers as to why the 23 year
old was shot
my grandson just got shot on a call with
9-1-1
casey goodson's grandmother says her
grandson has been shot as he
entered their home i just had the
gunshots and i would get up and he ran
in the door
the family says goodson had just arrived
home with sandwiches
just moments before the shooting goodson
was spotted by a sheriff's deputy
who was working as part of a u.s
marshal's fugitive task force conducting
a search for a suspect in the
neighborhood
goodson was not the target of the
manhunt authorities say
goodson was seen waving a gun as he
drove by
the deputy at some point after that he
confronted him
and it went badly police claimed goodson
then got out of his vehicle
and was ordered to drop his gun and when
he failed to comply the deputy
opened fire law enforcement has stated
at least one person heard that verbal
command and they say a gun was found at
the scene
but goodson family attorney sean walton
disputes that chain of events
saying no one from goodson's family
heard any confrontation
and that the 23 year old was killed in
front of them including several children
casey was executed while walking into
his own home and that's something that
curiously was left out of the initial
statement
goodson's families say that they did not
see a gun
on casey they also say he had no
criminal record and was a legal gun
owner and concealed carry permit holder
the question that needs to be answered
immediately is why was casey shot
for having a gun when he had every legal
right to do so
in an interview with cnn goodson's
mother says she
feels race played a part in her son's
death
because of the color of our black man's
skin they're not protected they become
targets and study somebody that they
have to protect
we are hearing from our columbus
affiliate that the
autopsy results are expected to be
released sometime this morning
the sheriff's deputy who is accused of
firing the fatal
shot is a 17-year veteran he's been
identified as
jason need anthony jeff thank you very
much
so many questions in this case we're
looking at this again
i can't either it's getting very old but
as you said there are a lot of questions
a lot
because the family says there was no gun
they said it was holding sandwiches
there's a big difference between a
sandwich and a gun i don't know what the
police officer saw
and we don't know what even led to the
confrontation really no
the bigger picture is this happens
disproportionately to black men versus
other men
and that's why it keeps coming up and
the other big question is he was
entering his own home yeah